and so doc right with Jose BA is
actually a completely different clone
version
she went full-blown evil well there is a
theory that Palpatine might have fetched
Luke's hand when it got caught then
that's when the voice of Palpatine came
is like I got your story about Darth
Plagueis the wives who knew a thing or
two about this welcome back guys I'm
Paul Malina this is rogue theory we are
taking a trip to the dark side with Ray
guys we have Erik Bosse hi I'm worried
anything Danny / caskey yes I'm not
worried yeah and Maude Garrett
I'm your right amount of worried yeah so
rogue theories the show where we take
fun people like this and we have them
bring some rogue theories too well don't
be so charmed you guys are fine they
bring their weird rogue theories to
whatever's going on in nerd news this
week so we're definitely gonna talk a
little later about some theories we have
about that new Joker trailer but the big
thing last weekend d23 the big Disney
convention where they drop all sorts of
Disney stuff probably the biggest news
out of it was probably this Star Wars
trailer that came out that specifically
showed a character with associated with
the color red and now we're like wait
did they go evil and I'm talking about
c-3po those eyeballs were terrifying
yeah we all have reaction maybe at the
pollen pollen buddy's like stoned off
reaction and we just are to just like
chill finally for once yeah
but instead let's talk about ray yeah
who at the end of that trailer is spooky
she's got a cloak she's got a not real
smart lightsaber design right the phone
I love that a video mean that was going
around where it's just like a Swiss Army
knife first saw like it eventually like
someone will show her up with like three
and then five
Blaz oh and light saver yeah oh just
like the movie really popular pride I
don't hate that
oh you don't hate kind of like you know
when Wolverine faced off and she had the
nails oh yeah
so I want to go down the line of a
couple of different things that could be
going on here when we see here all
spooked out like that yeah but I
let's stick one at a time because
there's a bunch of different directions
can go in so let's focus first on maybe
the most likely thing is it's it's some
sort of like illusion same thing it's
kind of like when Luke saw his face in
Vader's helmet it's like like could you
imagine the trailer breakdowns then and
they're like how did Luke's head so
first of all yeah I mean do we think
there's just some sort of forced
projection I mean it's very likely we've
already had that though in the last
movie where she had that moment in the
cave so I don't know if they're gonna go
doubled up on that one but it is very
ominous and it does look like you know
it's a projection because I mean JJ had
his mystery box in episode 8 it was
through in a spanner in the works which
is a wrench if you're in this country
I'm adjusting for somebody said that on
my Instagram recently they said I had a
face like a bag full of spanners it was
a bag full of wrenches otherwise if it's
just a projection then it's like what
using that against kylo or something or
like your mental self image right like
we've seen as mod was saying we've seen
force visions in all three or at all
three of these movies probably right JJ
had one with Maz Kanata in the in the
first one and then she had one in the
SIF cave in a second one and like
there's something about the background
of that shot it's only up on screen for
like two seconds but like it's kind of
this like metallic stone everything's
wet yeah background that kind of looks
like the aesthetic of those forest
visions so it wouldn't surprise me if
that's just where they're going with
this and that's why they're okay with
showing it in the trailer because if not
like what a huge turn to reveal this
early I feel like I feel like previously
whenever there's been some sort of force
vision though it was associated
with like a Jedi influence sort of like
showing the dangers of the darkside and
like if there is going to be a force
vision I would imagine it would be for
Rey to see like the possibilities for
her what would happen to her right do
you think that that when he said Jedi
influence do you think that you mean
like you know they're masters on the
outside like essentially putting
together their PowerPoint of life here's
the spooky things yeah that's what I'm
saying it's like somebody like maybe
Luke is actually like guiding her into
seeing that somehow I guess that could
be since he's like a portal into the
force
so yeah the visions kind of like a
scared straight for Rey you could be
when your minds on the docks look badass
but a faulty lightsaber that hinge is
gonna wear down at Luke Skywalker's
forced ghost in a dirty shirt oh dear
here's got the same color scheme as the
Sith that jacked lion was a Sith Lord yo
no but like I I don't feel like this is
just some sort of force projection
because of that like and it goes to Yoda
showing Luke that Darth Vader vision it
was in some of the cartoons where Anakin
went into like this cave and like saw
the possibility of him going to the dark
side and obi-wan was just waiting
outside for her for him and then when
Rey went down into the cave like Luke
was there on the island to sort of like
frame what she just saw and I feel like
particularly the fact that she has this
crazy new lightsaber it's like why would
we introduce a crazy awesome lightsaber
in something that is like a five second
imaginary bit merchandise haha which is
no my god I'm having a vision of me and
five looks and this one's purple yeah
for sure
speaking of I want to introduce we've
updated we have our rogue figures
throughout the episode we got a new look
of an anti Paquin this is exactly what
we're talking about
cloak because this rig is always gonna
be the best rogue in existence this is
the best iteration her and gambit as
well I mean this road was my first and
tenth crush so okay the rogue theory
that I want to explore is it's not a
bait-and-switch it's she's bad now and
some version of she's gone to the dark
side
maybe it's kylo Ren that needs to stop
her I like the idea that this whole
trilogy that everybody was comparing to
being too similar to the original
trilogy is actually gonna be too similar
to the prequels and it's about the
downfall of a character right and we'd
like except done correctly this time
where we liked them and rooted for them
didn't from when they were 11 years old
go like that kids a creep and is gonna
kill worst murder so if that's the case
what would motivate that you know why
would she why would she go down the dark
side
well rogue theories only alright going
rogue here I think the first time I want
to say we all probably had the same
reaction
the most common reference point here is
they're trying to allude to Darth Maul
with a double dual wield blade that's
and in that opening kind of montage of
all the pasts big moments they show
Darth Maul randomly even though Darth
Maul is one of the most famous things
from the prequels Darth Maul seems to be
having a comeback he had this big cameo
in a Star Wars story and one Harry
Styles rebels and they explained how he
came back and what he was doing during
the Clone Wars and and where he ended up
at the end of his journey with obi-wan
and one of the things we've learned
about him in Star Wars rebels or in the
animated series as a whole was that he
was heading up the shadow collective he
was spurned by Palpatine and he wanted
to play the whole Clone Wars with the
separatists and the Republic for his own
personal gain in the solo Star Wars
story the Kasden father-and-son team
decided to rename that the crimson dawn
and now that is his new syndicate
cult or crime organization whatever you
want to call it of which Kiera Amalia
Clarke's character was his like kind of
apprentice assistant whatever you want
to call it who learned Tara Scotty of
course two men name something crimson
dawn and didn't really understand what
it sounded like
[Laughter]
to kind of complete my rambling brogue
theory here I believe that it is
possible that there could be a
connection between Emilia Clarke's
character Kyra and Rey maybe she is some
kind of distant relative of it yes she
was told in the last Jedi that her
parents were nameless junk traders but
maybe through some kind of orphanage
through some kind of genetic engineering
where they had two patron this kid they
left her behind
maybe they owed money to the crimson Don
and now they had to look after this kid
abandoned her at some point on jakku and
through this lineage she is now bearing
the torch for the tradition that darth
maul started as someone who was spurned
by both sides of this sith versus Jedi
battle to forge ahead in a new tradition
of people who have horse abilities but
are on either side I think that I think
that that's really interesting because
something that's really notable about
the end of the last movie is now kylo
Ren and Ray are completely unshackled by
tradition you know like Snoke is gone
Luke Skywalker is gone there are no like
mentors there are no people that are
passing the tradition forward and like
it would be interesting if suddenly some
rebel faction is coming in to fill that
void so just to give you a backstory on
what happens when you are born a Jedi
and you have jedi ability you're usually
taken away to the Jedi Academy when you
were a baby yeah when you are an infant
and the fact that I think Anakin was 11
that was that he was deemed far too old
right right um and so if she's got no
recollection of her parents or you know
and she just you know was one discovered
in one of the most isolated planets
there is every chance that she possibly
would have gone to the academy or you
know she was taken from her parents at
birth but then something went down
we know that the Jedi Academy doesn't
exist anymore because ken went in and
killed everything right everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
messing with the broom it means that
there are shocking recta me I started
crying really because it could have been
you know no just because like I don't
know I thought that was really cool in
the second movie because it was rows and
Po going to that wild casino plan it
wasn't thin yeah it was Rosen fan going
to that time see no planet can't obey
and they they like passed hope on you
know yeah and like that kid didn't even
seem to notice that he had force powers
that think again that you were saying
where it's just totally unbridled there
is no regimented system anymore where it
was so kind of like clinical in a way
now it's just like they're running
rampant you know you're supposed to have
the light side which is represented by
Ray and the dark side represented by
Kyla but they can change so one of the
biggest things I feel like the last Jedi
was trying to say is that everybody's
wrong about everything about what these
movies are gonna be about for sure but
also about what you're what you learn
about the force and the fact that
there's a good side and a bad side and
instead it's like no it's it's light and
dark and that doesn't mean either side
is fully right home and so I do think
that Erik's theory here about this idea
that uh you know maybe they're there
it's not necessarily that she's gone
dark rather she's gone rogue right and
she and maybe also yeah her let's just
call her her brother and let's stick to
that theory for a second or whoever this
person is with kylo yeah maybe they're
for jeans some sort of new future of
we're completely ignoring the past
everything we'd been taught here's
what's working for us we're gonna use
the force you know in in these ways and
it we don't really care about the
religions that came before absolutely
dude I am so in that camp I think that
like the prophecy was that the Skywalker
would bring balance to the force and so
there's that idea that like Anakin might
have been the Skywalker that was
promised because before he destroyed the
Jedi Academy like the force was broken
you know like the Jedi's were like good
guys but they were bureaucratic they
allowed everything to tie their hands
behind their backs and they were used
it's the same way that Superman in
certain stories is used by the American
government to spread democracy but
essentially he's just like an
imperialist that is you know doing the
bidding of people that believe in
manifest destiny and it's like what
you're you're just a weapon now right
being used by other people you know it's
interesting is actually that is kind of
the idea of like Orthodox and then like
you know new versions of religions where
they're like look we're gonna eat what
we want to eat and we're gonna bone but
we'll be good to people basically
they're gonna start their own church
right I think that lay Jedi I think that
like we are absolutely moving towards a
more morally relative relativistic force
you know and I think that was that was
such a mouthful a more morally
relativistic force but like I think that
that was foreshadowed in the last Jedi
when they were having that lightsaber
battle against all those red dudes and
they were just trading lightsabers back
and forth Rey and kylo Ren were you know
Ray had kylos lightsaber for a bit kylo
had the blue lightsaber for a bit and it
didn't matter yeah and it also didn't
matter any kind of combat melee tactics
to those other guys who were just kind
of waiting for their turn let's wait
hold on let's associate you currently
are holding a one rogue theory and it's
essentially she's gone dark it's based
off of what Eric said but but I think
you took it to the point of but not
necessarily evil just she's she's kind
of grating our own thing Maude she's
good ray yep she's in a grey zone yeah
yeah she's great
Maude what's your theory a theory not
the one I read when I'm just thinking
I'm just then this is the first movie
that Ray doesn't have a mentor her whole
life she's being by herself she's been a
survivor she hasn't had anyone to show
her the ropes now she has all this
unbridled power within her
she had a mentor that was guiding her
through her journey he's now dead so
she's got this power and doesn't know
how to use it if you want a lot a strong
deeper amount of power you go to the
dark side because that is where like the
greater power is it's the Jedi that
makes better decisions with it but I
mean I think that that's something if
she needs on a map and a mess and that's
them out of power quite quickly she just
goes to that doctor where you learn the
cool [ __ ] I can tag team on this yeah I
think she needs it because like I saw
that and I was like she looks grizzled
she looks like she's in the future about
the crimson dawn for sure I think that
this is coming like way after I want to
imagine like this is the end of the saga
I want to see like an end of the series
sort of thing where it's like everything
settles and then we jump 20 years in the
future and see what's going on there and
I think like yo maybe maybe the first
order wins like maybe the rebels are
destroyed and like that pushes her to a
place where she needs to use the force
in a dark way I got a rogue theory what
if maybe she's going to the dark side
because she wants to know how to bring
back her friends who have died thinking
everything about this to me is like you
need to use the the weapon the bad thing
because it's the most powerful thing you
need to bring back your friends that
died she's gonna snap she's going to
star and say I wish I wish I could bring
back my friend han my friend Luke and my
friend Leia and then that's when the
voice of Palpatine came he's like I got
your story about Darth Plagueis the
wives knew a thing or two about this
it's called the rise of Skywalker what
if she is a Skywalker and she you know
Luke died and she realized she was lied
to her entire time yeah she's your time
it really is a Skywalker and there's no
one and you know maybe Leia dies as well
and so like you know her identity was
not revealed to her so she was like not
cool back what you the coin let's go
there everything we just said at the end
there implied that she's gonna do the
Tony Stark at the end of endgame where
she's just the one that is now that's
what you meant by snap yeah
her mind no I mean like she leans into
the thing that's been used against us
and because it's so powerful like model
saying like look you have to touch this
thing because it's so intense to do the
thing that needs to be done and it kills
Tony and who knows how it'll do for
right these are all interesting but yes
MA catch us up on this whole other rogue
Theory fantastic would love to we all
know that the the Clone Wars and the
whole Clone Saga was because there was
that secret planet kimono which wasn't
even in the archives they'll basically
creating the stormtroopers which was
based on a clone which is where we'd get
Boba Fett so it was his jango fett jango
if Jango Fett got cloned and ababa Fett
was his little son so we know that
cloning exists because there has been
such a lapse with Jedi and we don't
really know race history there's every
chance that Rey herself is a clone so
she is one of hundreds of maybe even
thousands that have been bred to become
weapons and if raised a Jedi then
there's every chance that they instead
of just cloning you know a super trooper
basically she's a Jedi and so doc Rey
with her saber is actually a completely
different clone version
she went full-blown evil whereas this
ray that we know it was just on jakku
the whole time living a pretty sorry
like it's a nature versus nurture right
but but that's really cool wait were you
saying yes capitaine who's behind it but
it would totally make sense totally
makes sense where they were like hey we
have this great assassin in Jango Fett
we should clone him and make a whole
army out of it and then someone a while
later was like shouldn't we used a Jedi
same person yeah the same person is like
a Jedi would have been even better than
one good assassin and so like fine let's
create an army of Jedi yeah that is her
there is also that would pay off two
things in my mind one is that vision
that she had where it's the hallway of
mirrors essentially of yeah like why am
i seeing myself as so many different why
there's so many of men that's her trying
to figure out her origin and remember
that some of the two things there one
she the mirrors don't behave exactly
like
her right she like she like move and
they don't necessarily move at the same
time so they're not actually her they're
not reflections or other instances and
she comes from no one
right her parents are it's essentially
herself as what she's seen yeah just you
baby
she a little test tube does that mean
there is a rape rhyme somewhere out
there who's just a little bit closer and
tired of having blood taken from her
well we were talking about this earlier
and all sort of Danny on this this idea
that well if you're a cologne you're
you've been cloned of someone so also
clone might be a misnomer yeah but what
would it mean then well there is a
theory that Palpatine might have fetched
Luke's hand when it got crazy the crowd
that's what you call it a baseball game
anyways they took his hand and then they
made clones based off of that
of course then Rey could not technically
be a clone of Luke because a clone would
have the exact same genetic clone of the
hand would just be another hand not
really study Daisy Ridley's body but
it'd be amazing if one of her if if she
were something like a clone
she has insane force powers it sounds
like she would be like a genetic like
super organism that like took parts of
like perhaps the strongest Jedi's or
like the strong Jedi genes got beefed up
a little obi-wan had a strongly every
day she's got that she's got a bit of
blood of mace windu that's why she can
throw the light say yeah she's been
pranked it signed together drops of
everyone's blood just like mix it up and
put in a photocopier and print out
another ray I'm gonna saying that works
one thing that people probably get mad
at but if you can clone a Jedi and the
force is like you you take advantage of
the copy and genetic material and the
force is like yep I guess that clone is
now a Jedi - then that means
midi-chlorians are a thing that is on
their DNA and is is the basis
that's validating which they are cannon
yeah they're cannon yeah so if you want
to find a way to fix that
maybe there's a weight something cool
you can do with it all right so so that
theory give me these
rogue figurines back you guys I feel
like I should have had possession of a
rogue at some point at some point I had
the hottest right gave you one and you
immediately lost I broke it but I want
to know okay so the clone theory isn't
so crazy so to push it more rogue let's
say she's not some genetically modified
hand clone instead she is a repurposed
clone of someone else with maybe like
you know a little changing who could she
be a clone of that we already know who
has to be a Skywalker though right but
well kind of but like you know I'll
throw out there some people have said
maybe Shmi Anakin's mom for potentially
like just we just seen throw out but she
was a vessel she was marrying at a
virgin birth yeah there was no father
I'm sure she loves being called a vessel
you guys must be answering knows she
could be imagine imagine a hot young
female Palpatine yeah but okay so
Palpatine right so Palpatine is gone
how does Palpatine come back maybe it's
through some sort of clone of Palpatine
did you see a body blue glow in a
lightning bolt that it's not a body
mm-hmm yeah that would be we do know
that Palpatine did clone himself and and
you know legends yes I don't know if
it's a cannon or not yeah that could be
part of the strategies he clones himself
but it would be a clone right because
clone has to involve a severed hand to
be imprinted by a printer these are the
rules of clones the yeah like maybe this
could be his idea is he has cloned like
he's just a source of it you know so he
has other little things around the
galaxy's sleeper cells if you will ready
to activate
whenever they are at their potential in
Rey was the one who surprised she's the
Dark Angel of this bunch the anomaly
that he is now selecting to carry on his
legacy I mean you can have a road please
like we know Kenobi's has his new series
right obi-wan there's been like theories
that he could have remember it is when
you hear the the force voice say ray it
is Obi Wan's voice just saying Ray da
mcginnises which is so funny they just
chopped up his audio from from a new
hope and they just found ways to make
him say whatever they want yeah right
yeah with Alec Guinness and Ewan right
didn't they bring in these theories or
do we feel like it's most likely she is
a clone and we're dealing we're seeing
bad clone Rey and I love Matt I want
because she it's her she's gone astray
maybe yours was maybe dark maybe just
her own way Graham or is it just a
vision let's let's seal it up for people
what's up would take the best lock it in
lock it in
I'm gonna lock in that it is coming from
the tradition of Darth Maul and other
Jedi like this who have been spurned by
both sides and are now trying to forge a
way that is neither one side a new
tradition that one might call lowercase
yes Skywalker
right that's my that's my final bad I'm
I'm also gonna land on the Garre because
I think that like a separation of the
size of the force was never right and
the Skywalker was meant to bring balance
and that was meant to like combine both
sides and I see Rey then as being more
of like a relativistic figure where like
she can be the destroyer and she can be
the creator and she represents both
sides of the force yes look if it was
Ryan Johnson directing this one I would
have said clones cuz he's batshit and
anything goes and he goes against the
norm because it's JJ
a very safe storyteller this is a vision
it's a vision okay all right whoever
wins gets a shirt yeah
I try to think what do you three have in
common I want to talk one more thing
about how you were going down this road
with Palpatine yeah theory of not only
how he might be back but why he might be
back but let's get into that right after
we thank some sponsors hey everyone Eric
here just a reminder that if you enjoy
the stuff we make here at new rock stars
you can find us not just on YouTube or
the podcast feed rogue theory you can
also subscribe to the podcast inside
Marvel for all of our Marvel news and
WikiLeaks our Star Wars podcasts with
all the inside scoops you need to know
about episode 9 the rise of Skywalker
the Mandalorian of disney plus and what
green milk straight from the
Architeuthis iron nipple tastes like
it's a taste of wishing you could unsee
something subscribe to rogue theory
inside Margot WikiLeaks and keep an eye
out for even more new content we got in
store for you guys we're back we're
gonna talk real quick we're gonna get
into the Joker actually but I just want
to wrap up one thing this return of
Palpatine is Palpatine back and I said
earlier you know I did you see a body
but also do we need to see a body does
he need a body could he just be a force
ghost yeah I mean Seth can have ghosts
of course gonna have a ghost right
although there's some different theories
on whether SIF can come back in in
ghostly spirit forms small has kind of
projected his image in some way or
another maybe it's just been sense but
we've seen an image of personally Yoda
was the one who had figured out how to
be a force ghost and only had passed it
on to qui-gon jinn and we don't know if
he was able to relay that afterwards but
now we've seen Luke as a force ghost so
who knows it could be one Obi Obi Wan
was at the end of all that because he's
his mentor was one yeah it's a good guy
actually if that's the case then because
Yoda also trained Dooku so Dooku would
technically have a force ghost just
chilling out like sandals be talking to
a
battle droid and Attack of the Clones
does it I think it's selective by the
force the force is like yo these bros
are super chill I'm gonna let them hang
whereas the bad guys the force is like
ooh not so chill maybe don't hang no I'm
saying like I'm saying like the force
wants to like absorb these folks and
like sort of keep them in the ether
because they're chill dudes and like
they had disrupt the vibes whereas like
the bad guys like we're gonna make the
party about their Plagueis doesn't have
a force guy stand by any right he really
should so let's remind everyone about
the you know have you heard like it's
the wise tragedy yeah so we don't know a
ton of the details on this at least in
the in the films but it's yeah it's
basically as if who had encountered the
ability to resurrect loved ones from
death there's also a theory that this is
just a story that a Sidious slash
Palpatine told Anakin which is oh what a
great story yeah but I mean Palpatine
knows that story if anyone's going to
cheat death it's gonna be him yeah you
know yeah resurrected I mean he kind of
brought Anakin back and he was like what
ninety percent dead from lava
he should rag I mean thinking about that
that sort of says like yo the Jedi's are
the ones that are like cool with passing
on and becoming part of the force and
the Sith those are they wanna get around
they're all about the Material Plane
like Darth Plagueis wants to stay alive
Anakin Skywalker was turned into a robot
just so that he could be alive and the
Material Plane for longer and there's
also like a few other examples of like
Sith Lords who were like yeah or who
possess objects right so there was a
darth nihilus who used his robes or he
kind of state his essence stayed on his
ropes and then there's a Momin who
stayed inside his mask which that was a
theory that we were talking about
earlier right that like maybe Vader's
mask and that could be like kind of
Horcrux if you want to cross other
properties in here like he's living on
his presence through the mask that
really is
sidious thing not so much an Anakin
Skywalker thing that was a armor that he
gave Vader to make Vader yeah worth
noting know you know you know we were
trying to follow the telephone chain of
who has taught who had a force protect
early just after but Real Estate's
anyone who's a certain level of powerful
we've seen them on the other side so it
follows that Sidious would be powerful
enough to have basically figured out for
sure even if you didn't learn it from
Yoda yes he's made a chlorine count 78
yeah you could definitely get a good car
loan with that yeah I'm struggling with
40 yes well you have glasses okay so so
there's that that idea that you know
he's been maybe he's possessing
something rubber but why this moment now
and also then what has he been doing for
30 years what's he been amassing maybe
guys time is just a construct you have
to understand everyone was on Tatooine
for 19 years and he turned into Alec
Guinness you know from Ewing whatever
these days yeah I mean there was a
theory that some we were talking about
this whole imperial star destroyer fleet
the first order would not have access to
these kind of old-school imperial star
destroyers same hundreds of them maybe
that could be part of Palpatine strategy
one thing we were discussing is that
maybe Snoke was a puppet not just a
literal looking puppet a nine foot tall
golden robed puppet and maybe Palpatine
Houston for his wealth
I don't really bird he was like saying
that he was like thousands of years old
right sure so I was thinking the same
thing that he was just a facade that was
being used as Palpatine almost like you
know parasite and he was using her time
as a construct to look like Ewan
McGregor so so you're saying he helped
Matt create the first-order kind of in
the background yeah that may be the
first order was some kind of uh it was a
consequence of operation cinder where
people didn't fully carry out
Palpatine's legacy his will and
testament so instead they they took
whatever scraps they had of the
shattered Empire and created the first
order but really there was another
agenda at play and we're
the effects of that agenda witness
massively to Star Destroyers this is
really what Palpatine's vision was after
his and and maybe through manipulation
of Snoke right yeah they're possessing
him or bullying cyber bullying maybe
another thing like if he has really been
gone and he hasn't been a collab or like
maybe he's just been watching cuz like
hey things are kind of breaking good for
his side for a while I mean the first
order was kicking butt yeah you know
maybe like Snoke was just like you know
that rich nerd who falls in with a bad
crowd and it's like oh we can trick this
guy we get money for our drugs and we
party to besieged mansion it's like I'm
friends with these people mom they are
my friends can we buy more handles of
Goldschlager as they want it for their
party that's a sad story
your kids friends this 68 years old or
something that's why you have that one
older rich kid in every fraternity we
solved it we I'm done I almost feel like
I don't need to see it now yeah instead
let's start with something we haven't
seen it we don't know anything about the
new Joker trailer we don't know exactly
what's movie's gonna be so excited to
get into just so that it says new
trailer dropped I and you can there's
stuff that what you're pointing out in
the breakdown that's really interesting
please stop messing with my son I just
want to like talk a little bit about
we're so I don't want to really try to
speculate a bit exactly what's gonna
happen I think we're just gonna be right
or wrong they'll say you're doing some
of that in the breakdown but I just want
to talk about what this thing is
actually about because the movie is very
clearly now showing that it's this indie
film that's taking these references from
from other great films we were talking
about earlier King of Comedy what else I
mean you could say taxi driver and
Charlie Chaplin's modern time right all
these kind of all of these things and it
feels like they're doing that they're
leaning into it so hard that it feels
like it actually has honestly nothing to
do with look like a superhero movie yeah
I mean I think
yeah almost an understatement that I
think it has nothing to do with fat man
other than maybe there might be a scene
in there that is very relevant to the
man involved in this because I feel like
with influences like taxi driver and
with king of comedy which he's also in
this really does feel like a de niro
homage like his previous films well this
is yeah this one that where Todd
Phillips was like maybe trying to court
Martin Scorsese to be a producer
executive producer and those are both
like Scorsese De Niro movies yeah I
don't think Scorsese is really involved
maybe Todd Phillips just pitched Warner
Brothers in like all right we're gonna
do a joker movie that's gonna feel like
the king of comedy it's gonna feel like
Travis Bickle but is De Niro like a
creative influence like is he producing
is he he's checked out on everything
meet the parents so my actual question
though is is again so what's this really
about if it's not about you know just
like an origin story for a famous
villain if instead it's a commentary on
society as it feels like that's an NGO
they're going on then what what angle
like I'll throw out there for instance
when I saw this new version of the
trailer to me even though it's set in a
tie-up pre-internet era they're still
trying to do that kind of viral video
like you know you're embarrassing
yourself on camera and then it goes
around and a million people see it and
then I guess you gets a web Redemption
something but that so then is is that
about that is about the social media
game what are we getting too political
if we say it's about the disenfranchised
white man and the N cell uprising yes we
are but society as a whole has gotten
too political these days but but we have
to look this is the world we live in
I'm not saying this to political is just
the world we live in now whether we like
it or not so yeah sorry reality is
political now doings been right now
famously Danny explain what you mean
well this is a guy a white guy who
people don't like it looks like he's
faced a lot of rejection yeah who's
faced a lot of rejection who clearly
really wants to be liked he's a comedian
that's all of us right anyone who's
faced a lot of rejection like strives to
be yeah yeah right
he needs validation and he's just not
getting it from society and so he is
like falling in with this like
anti-authoritarian like movement and
like pushing this agenda of like we are
going to like strike down these
institutions that are making us feel not
powerful you know and I think like I'm a
white guy and I've grown up thinking
like I am supposed to be powerful and
I've had to come to the realization that
none of us has very much Authority even
within our own lives you know right and
that's a hard realization to come to and
I think that hits a lot of people really
hard and makes them turn to like makes
them turn to like these people on the
internet who tell them like oh yeah the
system's screwed up and we've got this
great ideology for you you're really
fine you know what doesn't sound very
random or some people gonna be like
that's a stretch but what doesn't sound
like a stretch about that at all is that
essentially the concept there is a type
of person thinks that the order is
supposed to favor them yeah when the
order doesn't fail them then it's time
did you just disorder break down the
order introduced chaos and then who's
the most famous agent of chaos but the
Joker yeah right who just wants things
like to just dissolve any semblance of
structure yeah we'll have to see how
much like race factors into it based off
footage so far I don't I haven't seen
enough evidence to be like oh there's
gonna be a movie about like racial we
generally paints his face what you
should have seen the edit where he pans
face black yeah to me this is kind of a
story of fandom of attention of before
we had social media and the Internet we
did have people in show business who
wanted Fame famous occasion needed the
spotlight and that is a component of the
Joker's character is the show man
well they're noticing yeah he had to do
something to get noticed selling your
soul I think this is the story of how a
cult begins we're talking earlier about
the Charles Manson connections here
Charles Manson was a struggling artist
who did not find commercial success and
then who did he take that out on success
yeah yeah and his idea was interesting
another racial connection there was to
blame the Tate murders on the Black
Panthers and create helter skelter
characters like the Joker are based on
maniacal cult leaders Manson himself
didn't kill anyone
he got others to do his bidding for him
yeah and right now weirdly Manson is
like through Tarantino's movie and
through the new season of mind hunter
everyone's like Oh Charles Manson is
kind of in the zeitgeist again I hate
the word zeitgeist but this could be an
interesting story we've talked about how
the joke Joker is a cult leader this
could be the origins of how the Joker
corrupts the people on the fringes to
follow in his values as perverted as
they are totally zeitgeist means time
ghost before it means whatever you want
questions we are going to ask questions
I've never seen before and answer them
quickly and as rogue Lee as possible oh
great it's been announced that Eva
Longoria will direct a movie about the
invention of flamin hot cheetos what
what snack food actually deserves a done
movie I don't know if this is
everybody's favorite snack food but I'd
like to see a movie about pickles
defining as a snack food is already
unusual pickle me it's my favorite snack
I go to Costco and I get a big box of
them and it's like not box but whatever
this tub of pickles please I get a soggy
box of those sweet cucumbers
you know whatever the hell that is yeah
I'm down I think we got it the TSA has
banned special soda bottles a special
soda bomb from Star Wars Galaxies edge
at least in part because they're modeled
after thermal detonators in the trash
what souvenir a piece of March would you
be willing to get arrested for Batarang
it came in handy Wolverine claws I
actually I ordered some Wolverine claws
thinking they were toy we'll Vereen
claws off of Amazon or Ebay whoever got
them they were sharp as hell and I have
no idea what to do with them Freddie
globe once it was just like no I can't
ever movie not now use it to prune but
how do you dispose of it you don't want
to give someone remedying through the
trash access to that something that
sharp yeah for sure okay in an interview
this week the Russo brothers said Robert
Downey jr. never says the same line
twice instead he uses alternate takes to
always make it feel fresh what line or
theory that you said earlier in this
episode would you like to give a
different answer
I said terrorists Cassie earlier my new
take would be to not say that guys
that's it for this episode
I thank you guys so much for going rogue
unfortunately no one wins the the prize
rogue this episode I don't even tell you
how to play you never do
one day that and that person will bring
balance to the show guys
I think you guys so much for going rogue
investing story I guess Danny brewski
brickowski sorry who we can see not
selling your soul but you know I'm still
on are you the one we've got two minutes
or two episodes left
yeah and I'm also streaming on Twitch
you can find me on Twitch Twitter or
Instagram it's all Danny prick as cool
what are you up to now what can we see
you I'd like to be known as the more
DeLorean from now on I'm on all social
media and as at Maude Garrett two hours
two T's and if you're on YouTube geek
bomb deep bomb I brought back book club
because no no people read books yes
especially on YouTube
very little book yeah and then Eric oh
yeah you can find me at ei vas on social
media new rock stars this weekend and
going into next week a couple questions
we're gonna answer what's next for Hulk
and for she-hulk the new Disney plus
series we're gonna look into what's next
in black panther - it could name or this
could be could this finally be where
name work comes in and where exactly did
Loki go is there a deeper conspiracy -
what his role will be in his Disney Plus
series that has been staring us in this
face in this face the whole time real
quickly gonna just affect their last
week everybody kept making jokes about
Hulk and she all getting together
without acknowledging that they're
cousins they're cousins
yeah because she has his blood from a
transfusion so it's yeah look into it a
bit but also it's legal some places guys
you can leave the show as a podcast on
the podcast feed the Rope through thing
it comes out there first so if you want
to listen in your car and I don't know
why you do that but enjoy it yeah if you
want to get build up your road rage and
then also subscribe to the channel
subscribe to us anywhere we have our
Twitter feed at new rockstars tells you
when all this stuff is coming down in
case you don't listen to Eric's now you
can follow me at Phillip Molina on
Twitter and on Instagram I love you guys
3,000 wait
go see yay bye please get out get out
can I break one of these please
hi this is I gotta break one
[Music]